Former President
Donald Trump is now facing
mounting threats on multiple fronts.
One week after
he was arrested
here in New York,
Trump was back in Manhattan
for a deposition today
with the New York attorney
general Letitia James
as part of her investigation
into his business.
He is also trying to get his trial
for a sexual assault
and defamation postponed.
Meanwhile, in Georgia, the Fulton
County district attorney
is currently weighing
charges over
Trump's push to throw out
the 2020 election results there.
And in Washington,
there are new signs
that the special counsel's
probe into January six
and Trump's
handling of classified documents
is ramping up.
Back with me now to discuss
all of this is Trump's
former attorney general, Bill Barr.
Welcome back.
I do want to ask you, though,
about the latest legal move
we've seen from your former boss,
which is filing a lawsuit
against his former attorney,
Michael Cohen,
to the tune of $500 million in damages,
saying that
he allegedly breached his contract.
Do you think there's any merit
to that lawsuit?
I mean, all I've seen is newspaper
reports on it.
I didn't see what the substance
I didn't detect
any real substance to the lawsuit.
So when I was thinking about this today,
I was reminded of what the former U.S.
attorney general or U.S.
attorney
in the southern district of New York,
Jeff Berman, wrote about you in his book.
He said that you tried to kill
investigations into this
when it came to true Michael Cohen.
He said
when Barr took over in February, 2019,
he not only tried to kill
the ongoing investigations,
but incredibly suggested
that Cohen's conviction on campaign
finance charges be reversed.
Is that true?
Well, first,
he was he
he pled guilty before I arrived
at the Department of Justice.
And I didn't kill any investigation.
But
you know,
I think people did come to the conclusion
that even assuming the facts about
Trump were were correct,
that it would not have constitute an
illegal political campaign contribution.
But I didn't try to
kill any investigation.
And in fact,
you know,
I was gone from the Department of Justice
now for two years.
It's under the Biden administration.
If they thought that there was
something there,
they were free to bring it.
They were also free to
you know, to raise it with me.
And no one ever did.
Did you pursuing a case,
did you suggest that
Cohen's conviction on campaign
finance charges be reversed?
No. He pled guilty.
I didn't.
I felt the plea should stand.
I want to move on
to the other investigations,
because today
we also saw
one of your former colleagues,
the former
director of National Intelligence,
John Ratcliffe, go and testify
before the grand jury in D.C.
That's investigating,
of course, Trump's
actions on January six.
You've said that you believe
your former boss has dug himself a hole
when it comes to this investigation
and the documents investigation.
What do you mean by that when it
comes to the January 61?
No.
What I was saying was, you know,
I try to call him as I see him.
And there are some cases
or some legal proceedings
that I think have been unjust
and unfair to Trump,
including the Russiagate episode.
And the New York case
is both the civil case
and the latest criminal case.
I don't think they have any substance,
and I think they're broad
for political reasons.
But that doesn't mean everything
that Trump does. He's a victim on.
And I said he's frequently
his own worst enemy
and he digs himself holes
and he does
some things that are reckless,
that are clearly going to
give rise to investigations
and look into them.
And that included
both the documents in Mar a Lago and
the January 6th episode
and the events after December 14th
and trying to
reverse the election
when all the states
had certified their votes.
Do you think Pence's testimony
could potentially be damaging
to Trump or game changing
for that investigation?
I mean,
obviously, they
have fought hard
to get the testimony of people
who were in direct
contact with Trump and potentially
be their information.
Their evidence can be
can be crucial to making a case
if there is one to be made.
I I've been a little skeptical
about them able
to establish a case on January six,
but I don't know all the facts.
I've said all along,
I think the more significant case
or the one that appears to me to be
most threatening
are the moral of the document case.
Why do you think that one's
more more threatening to him?
Because, you know, when it first came out
that he had the documents,
a lot of people sort of immediately
ran and saying, you know,
why didn't the government seek them,
talk to him about it?
Why didn't the government subpoena it?
Why did they
why they had the raid
and so forth or the search?
And it turns out,
as I suggested,
that they jawbone them for a year
and a half.
They did subpoena him
And I think the real question
there is not
whether he kept the documents
and had them in Mar a Lago
so much as once this was raised with him.
And it was clear
that he was being asked
to return the documents
as the government's property.
The games were played
for quite a long time,
and I think that that exposes him.
Do you think?
Yeah.
Do you think he can be charged
on obstruction
only here, or does there need to be
an underlying crime, in your view?
I think in this
case, the the underlying offense
was his having these documents,
which he shouldn't have had,
and he was subpoenaed.
And if he doesn't provide them
and hides them from the government,
there's both an underlying
offense
and there's the offense of obstruction.
But the thing that I think actually
brings this,
you know, that raises this
and makes it a more significant
threat is the obstruction aspect of it.
And I you know, I'm not saying, you know,
I just think there's a high risk here
and just based
on the government's conduct here,
I suspect that they have some evidence of
that.
They would consider it
to be strong evidence of obstruction
and that's why
I feel
that this is
probably the most threatening case.
What do you mean by that
based on what
the government's doing here?
Do you mean
because of how aggressively Jackson
investigation is progressing?
The fact that he was able
to talk to Evan
Corcoran, one of Trump's
defense attorneys,
without the shield of attorney
client privilege,
what is it
that that makes you realize
that it might be a serious case
for your former boss?
Well, they did
you know, they did puncture
the attorney
client privilege, as you said,
through the so so-called crime fraud
establishing before the judge
the crime fraud exception,
which was to say
there was probable cause that
there was evidence of a crime here.
So
that and, you know, just
the things I read in the newspaper
make me feel that
there's probably a likelihood
that they have people,
people who have cooperated
with the government
and may be able to establish that.
He well knew
he had not delivered
all the documents back to the government.
It's a pretty extraordinary case
if they do move forward with it.
If you were the attorney general,
do you think
you could feel comfortable
moving forward
with indicting a former president?
Well, you know,
I think that this is the kind of case
that requires a lot of discretion,
a prosecutorial discretion.
And one of the things that I think
is appropriate to consider is, you know,
what would this do to the body politic?
You know, the precedent it sets and
and having to deal
with the question of uneven justice,
people will point to Hillary Clinton
and so forth.
And those are legitimate points
to consider.
And I'm you know, I'm not paid
the big bucks to make that call.
Right now,
so I'm not going to offer my views on it.
But
one of the things I've said
is that the appointment of Jack Smith
makes me feel that they have decided
not to
That if the facts are there
to sustain a case,
that it's a supportable case
that would ordinarily be indicted,
that they've made the decision
to indict it
and that they're not going to tank
the case
because of
these discretionary considerations.
That's now this has
you know, that was my view before
they found
the president
Biden had taken some documents
and Vice President Pence.
And that complicates things.
So, you know,
we'll see where it falls out.
But again,
I do think that
that's the most serious thing facing the
the former president.
And you see the distinction
because obviously
the obstruction
factor is
what's at play with Trump's situation.
That's not something
that's been brought up
when it comes to Biden
or when it comes to Pence.
I do want to ask you,
because Trump's
not just facing these investigations
obviously he's facing
the one here in New York,
maybe one an indictment and in Georgia.
Do you believe that
presidents and former presidents
should be categorically immune
from being prosecuted
by these elected state
and local prosecutors?
What's your what's your sense of that?
Well, obviously, they're not
categorically immune from it.
I mean,
if the former president goes out
and commits
a crime in a particular state, a clear
crime, then
then they're not
immune from prosecution simply
because they're the former president.
But this is something that really
is completely hanging on a federal law,
a federal offense.
And
this is a local prosecutor
doesn't have jurisdiction
over the federal offense.
And he's basically
premised on
this is that the president
violated a federal law but
the president would be entitled
to have that determined
by a federal court and a federal jury.
And and so that's the problem here,
is that he's
for clearly,
I think clearly partizan reasons.
He's dredged up
this offense
and is trying to bootstrap it
into a felony
and go after the president with it.
And the federal government
has never pursued this
either.
When I was in office, as far,
you know,
they never brought it to me
as a potential case
against the president.
And after I left,
it hasn't
been raised as a potential offense.
So if the federal government isn't,
what would that be?
Because if he's a sitting president,
the idea that he couldn't be indicted.
No, I said after I left.
So after the president left office,
no one has as far as I'm aware,
the Department of Justice
is not pursuing this case,
because the problem with the case
technically is that
the payment of hush
money is not a campaign contribution.
It's a payment of a personal expense.
And the issue then becomes
whether it would have
been made irrespective of the campaign.
And that would
be very tough to show here.
So I don't think I don't think it is
a federal offense.